ما الذي يعرفه الأوروبيون أننا لا نعرفه
أو العكس
، لا أعتقد أنهم يعرفون شيئًا
مختلفًا عما نعرفه ، أعتقد أن
هناك ما يسمى
بالتوازن حول هذا السؤال ، ما
يعنيه اتزان الصدى هو أن بعض الدراسات تظهر
أن إعادة العدوى هي  أقل شيوعًا
بعد التعافي مقابل الحصول على
اللقاح ، وتظهر بعض الدراسات
عكس ذلك
، وإذا جمعت جميع البيانات
معًا ، فمن
المحتمل أن تظهر أكبر دراسة أن
الإصابة مرة أخرى هي في الواقع أكثر
حماية من اللقاح
الذي كان في إسرائيل ، والأهم من ذلك أن إسرائيل
تعطيهم  لقاح فايزر فقط كل
ثلاثة أسابيع على حدة ، لذا فهو ليس أفضل
لقاح ولكن إذا جمعت كل البيانات
معًا وقمنا بتجميع
البيانات على مدار 15 شهرًا ،
فربما نكون في موقف تكون فيه
الإصابة مرة أخرى شائعة بنفس القدر
إذا كنت
سابقًا  مصاب بالعدوى مقابل
اللقاح ويمكنني بالتأكيد التحدث عن
الوضع في جنوب إفريقيا ،
حسنًا ، أتحدث عن الوضع في
جنوب إفريقيا  نقطة من القول
إن ذلك لم تتم مراجعته بعد من قبل الأقران ، ولكن
ما هو الأحدث ،
فما هو مثير جدًا للاهتمام ، أعني أن
كل شيء جديد تمامًا مع متغير omicron
لدينا حرفيًا أسبوعًا
ويومين من
البيانات ، المشكلة هي أن السبب الطبيعي
قد يكون التعافي من العدوى
متغيرًا في الواقع لأنه
يمكنك أن تصاب بمرض شديد حقًا
لسوء الحظ ، ومن ثم
يكون لديك بالفعل مناعة
أكثر قوة ، ولديك خلايا تي أقوى ولديك
أجسام مضادة تستمر لفترة طويلة ، إذا
كنت تعاني من مرض أكثر اعتدالًا ، فإن
العكس هو الصحيح.  هل صحيح أن الأجسام المضادة الخاصة بك من
المحتمل أن تنخفض بسرعة أكبر ،
ويستحق اللقاح نفسه مع
اللقاح بالطريقة التي
لا يرفع فيها لقاح أسترازينيكا نسبة عالية من
الأجسام المضادة كما تفعل لقاحات mrna ،
وبالتالي قد تكون أقوى ولكن بعد ذلك مرة أخرى ،
تمتلك Madeira  لقاح مرنا أقوى من لقاح فايزر
بجرعة أعلى ومدة أطول
بين الجرعات ، لذا فإن كل ما تم تجميعه معًا
هو أنه معقد ، إنه مختلط وفي
سو  في إفريقيا ، بدأ برنامج اللقاح
بالكثير من الأسترازينيكا في
البداية ، وقد بدأ بالفعل في وقت متأخر كثيرًا
عما فعلناه هنا في الولايات المتحدة ،
ليس لدينا حتى معدلات التطعيم في
جنوب إفريقيا 23 25 الآن وكانت
معدلات الإصابة السابقة أقل.
من المحتمل أن تكون شديدة ، لأن السكان الأصغر سنًا ،
كل هذا يجعل الأمر
معقدًا ، لقد مضى وقت أطول منذ
أن أصيب الناس بالعدوى الطبيعية
في جنوب إفريقيا ، ثم أخيرًا
أن الورقة التي أشرت إليها للتو
أو البيانات التي أشرت إليها للتو
لا يوجد أي
ذكر للحماية  ضد
المرض الحاد الذي بدأنا
نفهمه أننا سنشهد الكثير من حالات
إعادة العدوى سواء تم تطعيمك
أو ما إذا كنت قد أصبت سابقًا
بعدوى خفيفة في الأنف
بفيروس مستوطن عالي المستوى
.  سوف نرى ما هي
الحماية من المرض الشديد هذا
هو السؤال الأساسي